foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the last thing I wanna do is ever lie to
you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I feel bad
in a fun land where Everything feels
like in concerned where people don't
don't know understand why am I so afraid
to take a chance they talk about it I'll
be about it cause the scars to show I've
walked through it and for the skies
marching on they say move up we say
never no boxer free and yet you ask me
for a Visa and a good reason oh I know
oh oh I know they think that's bigger
than you they think that's bigger than
you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]
I know that is
come on
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
many many years
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
pray that we all naked sending love to
the ill-fated body ready to jump now
simmer down jump now simmer down
pray that we all make it sending love to
the ill-fated but they're ready to jump
now
simmer down jump now send me down
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
awesome
[Music]
[Music]
praise
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'll be good
[Music]
I don't know what the future brings let
me go tell me good love now another time
another place to
pretended
every season they come to an end I don't
know if I see you again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when I'm rolling with my people
everything pretty solid how we walk
how we move when I'm rolling with my
people everything pretty solid
S I took it online
[Music]
hello how you doing
let me see here you say yeah yeah
[Music]
say yeah yeah
so I'm gonna play a new song
I have an album coming out in a couple
of months
and this is one of my favorite songs of
the project is called Dracula it's a
song about being tired of being used
overlooked dismissed
and all that
stuff
[Music]
yeah the waiting on us the gunman not
the florist
the gimmicks here we sing to it so bye
bye boom Solace the kids got nothing to
eat
I'm not gonna know what to be
the time is still gonna take it yeah we
live around the block from around the
block it might seem like we'd be
snoozing we are locked Around the Clock
I was sitting on jams but they're not
checking for we if you come with
disrespect you know you're gonna cut
your spray yeah
[Music]
let me see your hands up in the air come
on
[Music]
me they're gonna have to move her
carefully carefully gonna taste the
fruit of definitely definitely coming
out pick up your best believe yeah
another way they'll never be I wanna see
the people feed you open up their eyes
and seeing that is unnecessities so yes
respectfully we shall be challenging the
things we need and that is a necessity
[Music]
yo don't trigger my trigger I got dreams
way bigger than where I'm at and that's
a fact yeah yeah so excuse me
I'll take him to the cleaners and take a
little breather the wild wanted dogs
around here huh the dogs eat dogs around
here you think I'm a [ __ ] in the wheel
yeah well this cough wants a new deal
[Music]
what's up Frozen
[Music]
never came from me care for me they're
gonna have to move I carefully carefully
gone taste the fruit of definitely the
Folly coming out of your best believe
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign